comenzó en el metro de Santiago la
subida del pasaje del sistema de
transporte fue la llama que prendió el
descontento social en Chile en 2019
entonces masivamente estudiantes
saltaron los controles y entraron sin
pagar a las estaciones una primera
muestra del malestar colectivo que
terminó en multitudinarias protestas el
expresidente Sebastián Piñera eliminó la
medida Pero esto no calmó los ánimos al
contrario expuso la inconformidad por la
desigualdad y la discriminación en una
de las mayores economías
latinoamericanas con al menos 34
fallecidos y más de 2000 Víctimas de
represión policial solo el anuncio del
proceso para redactar una nueva
constitución logró cierta calma un
acuerdo por una nueva constitución
dentro del marco de nuestra
institucionalidad democrática así en un
primer plebiscito el 26 de octubre de
2020 los chilenos aprobaron dejar atrás
la Carta Magna promulgada durante la
dictadura de pinochet los ciudadanos
acudieron masivamente a las urnas a
pesar de la pandemia del Kobe 19 y la
propuesta fue aprobada con 78% de apoyos
una nueva votación llegó en mayo cuando
chile escogió los 155 constituyentes que
darían forma a la nueva Carta Magna dos
tercios de los elegidos fueron
ciudadanos independientes y opositores
de la izquierda y el centro izquierda
las labores comenzaron en julio de 2021
en cabeza de Elisa loncon una líder
mapuche
s
en un chile plurinacional la redacción
no estuvo ajena la polémica
enfrentamientos entre los constituyentes
críticas de una supuesta ideologización
e incluso la renuncia de uno de sus
miembros Rodrigo rojas después de fingir
padecer cáncer entorpecieron el trabajo
aún así el 4 de julio de este año
Gabriel borich el nuevo presidente y ex
líder estudiantil recibió el texto el
momento
[Música]
adicional social que ha vivido nuestra
Patria en décadas
los chilenos y chilenos los chilenos
optamos por más democracia y no por
menos la polarización marcó los últimos
meses hacia el plebiscito final hasta el
último minuto la campaña por el no se
mantuvo fuerte las posturas se medirán
en el escrutinio de este domingo